okay a bunch of play beams yeah I gotta
fix as much
it's like psycho power like is anything
ever set up when you start a video like
do you just do you have any thought into
planning now I I don't know as you can
tell I know we're going to play this
game called the final on station and I
think the game is it's going to speak
for itself you know what I'm saying yes
I'm wearing a white bitter it's a very
hot out here it's all I could say Oh Oh
Georgie Samson oh great passionate price
you don't waste a ball here like that
that guy was at I said actually I'm just
LAPD okay yeah exactly like that you see
guys you like that you say Jesus what
the heck how does this a might I thought
I was on a train or something is this
how far is this thing go okay maybe I
should explore a little bit more than
that Jesus what Danny let the eggs in
here Oh what's going on here sorry I
don't pay my dues
strange fringe okay
what to heckler that oh I want to Train
okay good morning
good mining where am i gun I got to
fight someone can't go out here at the
window no I got some coins I'm a and I
got some coins give me that give me that
sweet corn been good I'm not ready to
leave yet so find that house there was a
train it's looks like a train
I just can't open here yeah it's a house
I think there's like gutters already
trays on top gutters okay hello that
sure is pretty gross all citizens need
16 another must attend the annual sex
and visitation jail at the local
response shelter next drill is scheduled
on Friday thank you I'm 15 now this
guy's horrible running we're - forum
hello sir hello AR other tonight Martin
is not here today disappeared somewhere
hey sterilized work today okay
is that Mars whiskey kettle Mart and
just paying it by nothing can't jump
against now hello Scottsdale ah ha la
vacation is upper yeah better than
Sanchez screws what the heck
what'd I do oh I got outfit sick uh-huh
can actually close the door I didn't
pick what you watch them into the window
that's kind of weird
this used to appear real quick toilet
paper had you okay I can't press tab yet
tab I'm over switch controls
I think cue is med kit though was it you
should good idea he's not the best train
operator would so it was wrong calm down
keep an eye on and change this a very
important train I know
seven nine to eight uh I'll just a short
the damp but clothing here's it it's
looks like a bus station train station
oh no hello sir
I'll go away they installed the new
blockers thank you bout time
boss close code in the office and turn
the pan let's to the Train give more
details as we travel okay let's trade
Scotty
okay seven nine to eight
that's right get beyond parallel power
and hell out power
why hop it like that I'll take a
shudders one now I can move med kit to
ten three to ten
now leave that there
battery 100 using 934 tells you what I'm
using it for operators crafting assist
now okay
train is not in good condition this
experimental model frequent operational
failures you need to set it up manually
it would overheat you'll build a move
what is it that deprecation a doubt - I
do
what is this talking about that's it
subscribe what is this do is hungry
Allah sir
now in order to lio station you need to
get an access code from the station
manager I write
I think some people did that's what I'm
about zero is they're safe to this game
there's no safe okay you can't just like
leave your light there's no Express
train today you'll have to take those
recommend what a jerk
hello how's your vacation I say I don't
have the blocks cook the boss has it you
want to lunch you can wait here look
from the Senate okay I get gone there
blockers or twice much work to do with
eighties in the government locked it's
great it's beautiful out here
sister boss not now
I'll say the new cashews also get right
Hammond find a new one classes cashiers
pretty bad I guess I should talk to
everybody is a man saying I can't talk
to anyone I like my hat though and I
like how he runs with self-possessed on
his life you know okay hello thank you
getting a squall to the west coast
unresponsive story aunt I wonder what
can they going on Allison uh-huh
get up at 6:00 for drink order milk run
five miles or plate every day you gotta
sit there you got it yes why distract
any homework sex is just the loss now
can I go in here now right this is going
to be a lot to do then find a pressure
Adam I couldn't find a perch Adam you
just say your swallow if we do indeed
coyote tour big bulk okay fascinating I
can't go up anymore
set the boss you so much yeah crunch
sorry with strained Keys he had a
suitcase
let's go and Locker goat a anything set
to cut yes yeah all right sorry
what the heck has gone on here the hell
why don't the cars work a chapel here
from the Morganstern to find that two
screws one screwed Oh fascinating and
cookie going right and let share this up
as I do it again and I goes it if we did
it have a way did it music is very sad I
have to add Matt
food to it 10
why does it say reward twice like make
them channel what answer they told us I
can't blow that why is this marketing
great fair system perfect
am I like I don't know what the plane is
here Peter white welcome back thank you
now planned road changes however
communication problems in the South team
to fix it me - Peter offline strange
and
- this thing like always messed up I
guess we just literally just wait
mm-hmm I'm just a good captain yeah
anyway Iraq let's get out here oh sorry
so do you get like a lot of people all
right this one's a wet
got some ranks and neatly Michael has
I'd leave my constables with Patrol
hello sir hello the cat
oh yeah the cat maybe I sell so is there
no saving in this game let me just check
real quick
fascinating not great I think you start
at a level hmm all right
yes yes yes yes yes yes
the cub to coat the cup sags yes yes
what's going on here lock to the scanner
faster
towards going on here lesson they can't
so I'll take it to the South but I need
to go back home
it's important okay I'm money thank ya
thank you the details it worked -
Council no no nonsense
weird plus what's going on I'll a police
officers hello vivo how are you gonna
take it there huh now we hate to gun our
luxury come with mam comes out okay
money a one bar I don't understand
cell
alright that John again I repeat the
ticket office is closed to all
destinations not my brother's not me I
am I trying you know I'm sign her goes
there get up there now I already to
utter I don't have that look at my hat
I'm so happy I'm just follow I can you
ask the kitchen where as I made all
right where's the mate backhoe triple
cook so nice stuff and I'll take it boy
back
they know something's up they know
something as up was that our rat stupid
rat
the heck is going on here so thank you
that sorry you lost
his face is like smashed up
then I can't back out of every si
get the heck out of here okay well we
buck this place sucks actually
spice like really sucks 7th or 8th
getting soaked out here so they're eight
seven
Aquabats on the press that music will
get some water now you need water to
survive in the Sahara shows are well
everything is broken it's fine it's fine
can I choose where to go who don't lie
so emergencies you lost connection does
not good what does that do speed
yes I'm just like watching this
oh you have to say fire softballs okay
this one's horrible joint exact barely
working
you hear shooting
I don't know yeah i okay there sow sow
and sigh jams and now it happens
so what's going on
try not to get ahead I met
ooh a clone complete and it's a good
money I made some good money
oh this is not good am I going to get
fired up a dining outside
against firearms sect
great all right nice I'm sorry
say it
okay and yeah I made up water
where I guess I'm kept them pals ah Anna
I got those texts I pounds that's
disgusting
I am I going out here this doesn't say
they can't good plan and you're shittin
they're back
gunpowder hello sighs Bakken oh yeah now
one swing his hair they'll be here 20
minutes less sometime right now why are
you a dick down what's up bro
new cost field
ten minutes
okay and 11 I'm going down you know
something's gone on you were to be dying
up there oh gosh dang you know it's just
like on calls for honestly hello sir
and here right now
take that luck into good I'll be honest
Wow
if you go off the cents
Jennifer's seniors taken infirmary okay
I got the cut
she's a little jerk at age six nine
there we go that smoke at Rell's dogs at
the cargo alright don't take up some
space on my turn
trying to take already badly running all
right I got another thing to worry about
classified classified
all right say where I got Wallach I
think that places they said was
destroyed
that noise
what's a hat correct
just let our knit
look at that man yeah
necklace how you going to Redmond now
sorry
fascinating
just fascinating
I want that here yeah bet there you're
right there that make it not a charge on
Jennifer shoot Shawn
so it's ok because I really need it a
pestle thank God
with 12 any ammo tempting want it to
build Guardian like mechanics males
double petrol brightest
the current routes
I haven't yet done alone it is I named
mark am i scary
how to pop this sucker
Oh
how to pop those suckers quick I know
imma look great
is that what the mission just get the
thing and keep on going this is the
final station
yeah whatsoever or that like do for me
okay four nights at Oh get the hell
outta here probably didn't need to get
shot up but I did so I got just healer
sooner sad you're not very sad to be a
train off where to get paid minimum wage
you know it was close
okay so messed up this one's messed up
and that a okay this is good
perfect
yeah what is going on all right there
yeah I must
Melford I took this place they said it
like destroyed
should this star my life I read it
okay and a sign of what I won all right
[Music]
what happens it breaks down okay time to
i-10 download some pack so now they have
two shots I better make an account
that
Jesus getting a little scary
hello yeah
character
you like what you see here
Jesus
okay I used up like a lot of ammo
why am i when I supposed to be down I'm
like okay here we go
[ __ ] nonsense
Jesus so two bulls per person and wish
there was a better way to do this yes a
dad here at that okay
Oh perfect
like I did there
rags we're wakey so I could actually go
back now
crap
check it that Kay
so you could just do it empty
great
hmm
let me get the heck out of here Jesus
okay note to self
I need enough ammo to get back okay
heck them sometimes it only takes like
one shot yeah right guy let's just
finish off this fool
okay
okay let's get tech out of here get the
heck out of here and it's kind of good
toe can scan it and it's kind of scary
I mean I don't have that much ammo so I
should save it okay yeah what's going on
here
yeah well this is junk just lately I
need on that red lady she's hungry
hmm [ __ ] you're hungry captain
so we have some mud bullets yeah yeah
maybe that's peso drunk how about sir I
guess there's nothing you do with foods
I always will give them right
come on
we got to be like right there like
halfway there
mmm mmm mmm [ __ ] so hungry she's like
dying here
hey buddy don't say I'd do anything for
you
can I just like make them all oh yes I
can do that you can tell that a whack
down anyways already there yet
we're like almost there better get you a
game on you know
okay let's see what's up with this
hellhole cap it works on Trent NMR right
maybe it's for the pastor now so we
shoot in the face it's like better
really don't wanna shoot that yeah I got
your like hats down here we do things a
certain way here
like that
could I call it a spa Cho hate these
things he says they're Mata Austin
travelled small of a blob of last
backside spin pistol ammo a lotta ammo
cheese's
good luck what the heck
Jesus [ __ ] City healed
come over here Falls come on I like you
can't close doors
lock the heck okay eight two three seven
chase s
what is this lady
okay here we go
come on
she says
say say what is this kind of give this
battery
what the heck can I do this better
yes I know very sad yeah I just run
through it all
I'm out here though great
I need the battery get is insane that's
the worst thing I've ever heard okay
good thing I can like carry the
batteries right
that's justice yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
lets us do this yeah yeah now that one's
messed up
hi they need a battery I know the code I
want to practice used to go without
getting it except Channing on toast
every time
come on come on oh right yeah
now
nine three six eight
come on come this way
okay
all right we're going to exit here we
can edit here that's the race x8 yeah
right now let's blow this all deal
thanks for watching and see ya next time